do you think
that
do you think that
only fans models will be on the streets
in 40 years
or do you think they'll find a simp to
marry them
not on the streets but knowing something
that they they'd want now so like they
could be in the flashy apartments now
okay but in 40 years could be something
like down and out okay that they didn't
want but they can't afford anything else
yeah i think i think with the way
with the way men are they'll probably
find us him they'll find us out he'll
find a film
um i don't think they'll be would you
say on the streets okay
um
they
they will help they'll have a fine
though
they'll have a hard time finding um
a man
who would um
take them in essentially
you don't think they'll find anyone
um they'll find someone
but probably not the high quality men
not the one they want they'll find
someone okay what do you think
i i think they'll still find someone
because
it will become more normal now for a man
to meet somebody and for them to have
said
previously i had an account on only fans
obviously that didn't exist before and
it's not the same as saying i work on
pornhub
cornhub cornhound
okay go ahead
i honestly like the amount of money most
of them make i wouldn't see them being
on the streets in 40 years okay i just
can't envision
all that going stupidly i mean i can
because it came quick so it's going to
go
but i feel like they won't be on the
streets because if no it's gonna sound
quite wrong but if they're smart they'll
just have a baby by a rich man that
wouldn't keep giving them money to give
fund their lifestyle which a lot of
females do do so i feel like these
pretty girls that everyone says are
pretty and they're only fans whatever
because look at the looks or whatever
you want to say they might then find a
guy because they're pretty to just fold
into their bs and live happily ever
after if the women have to graft they're
the ones that might end up have nothing
because they've had to craft like drake
baby mama
yeah but she got lucky that's what's up
in hot sauce and stuff so you know yeah
i mean i think he learned and that's a
that's the thing i was saying about men
saying want to scout your seat and throw
a seat that's great protect yourselves
because women out here some women out
here are on crud and if you look a
certain way and you've got certain money
you are going to be the one paying child
support for kids you didn't want
unless you're going to blow out so you
know it's very very cool that's the
other thing the laws are against men
it's not even illegal for a girl to
steal a condom
it's not disseminate yourself it's not
illegal that's crazy no that's so bad
and the other thing is um we're
incentivized to do bad behavior
because you just you just said it right
so we're rewarded for bad behavior we
get pregnant by the wrong guy do you
think that men should be able to have
financial abortions since we have the
right since we have the right not to be
a mother should they have the right not
to be a father oh
that's a really rough one i cannot sell
right yeah go ahead yes i think i think
i think it's very upsetting
when
you've done the act which was great you
loved it lasted three minutes whatever
had to put it in there no we've done
that
and then you've now got the consequence
of the act yeah and it's very
and it's very upsetting when a guy
doesn't want the child and the girl
saying i'm going to have it anyway
because i feel like the man has any
every right to walk away yes she's made
a human and it's very unfortunate
but he didn't he doesn't want it he
doesn't want any to do with it you can't
then force a guy to have the child keep
the child or pay for the child it's on
you now sis as i would say to girls if
you're going to have a child make sure
you can financially support that child
before you say i'm going to keep it
because if you can't don't go and blame
no man for not being there it's
different the man said have my child i
love you we're gonna go together you
believe him you're going together and he
leaves but if you're there saying i want
a baby i want a baby then whatever
happens during your baby is between you
and your baby as well as where i see it
right and it's rewarding bad behavior
yeah definitely consent it's
incentivizing girls to
catch a kid off of a rich guy
that's something to some girl that's
their dream their dream is to find a
rich man have his baby and be cool
that's how some guys take their kid from
the from the woman they can because
there was a certain story that he's a
basketball player he's quite young he
had a baby by a woman who just wanted
the baby to get child support so he was
actually going through battles to try
and get the child to live with him he
hasn't got a pain in my child support
because it's crazy what she did a lot of
women do do that i'm really really
against single parenthood and women
trying to have babies just for money i'm
really really against that right it puts
the kid at every statistical advantage
that you could possibly put it in
yeah disadvantage yeah yeah i hunt and
agree i disagree why would you want to
why would you wouldn't he bring a child
into this world no not got a father that
makes makes no sense especially a father
that doesn't want them it's selfish it's
absolutely selfish percent because
you're you're putting your your want for
a check above a child
instead of finding the million guys that
would probably date her if she's
attractive enough to get a guy from a
like a baby from a rich guy i think it's
very situational because there's like we
can't speak for all women but there are
a lot of women who could get pregnant by
mistake and they physically cannot oh no
a child no not from a rich man no not
from a rich one just genuinely like okay
got pregnant they physically i have
friends who are like maybe i'm not ready
but i can't physically bring myself to a
report anywhere right right so there's
very little there's six there's six
layers though of protection one you can
get you can get an iud if you don't get
an iud you can do you can get the pill
if you don't do the pill you can take a
morning after pill if you don't do a
morning after pill you can do an
abortion if you don't want to do an
abortion you can give the kid up for
adoption and i think i missed one
because i'm pretty sure oh and and you
can require and you can require the men
that you sleep with to wear a condom
so there's six layers of protection for
a woman all the man has is a condom and
so if you pull out what it can pull out
but that's not good it does work no
it lowers the charges not that it works
[Laughter]
so at some point it's a choice she made
a choice hundred percent i think also
ella one for example it's 120 hours it
works up to 100 it's just five days yeah
women there's no no no your body clock
because you can take no no pills no no
and know when you're fair time not fair
tell that's the first thing you need to
do as a woman know your body and seven
track your yeah check your side seven
track your cycle okay cool didn't check
the cycle didn't wear condom there's a
one after the one after paul which is
which is 20 72 hours afterwards but
worst case now you've got five days cyst
to sort your stuff out and you don't at
this point you can't bring a number
yourself what's the choice at that point
i mean you had seven seven layers it's
literally a choice
yeah my mom got pregnant when she was 17
with my dad but they gave her the kid up
for adoption
wow yeah and then we we meet him later
later his name his name is greg he's
pretty cool
but i think it's about being it's about
bff yeah we're sure about decision at
the time because she wasn't going to be
selfish
she was selfless she thought about the
kid before her
a lot a lot of a lot of other young
adults are not young people but
a lot of people don't necessarily think
about that concept i think of everything
not being married being single whatever
you're going to start bringing kids into
this world even men want to scatter
their scene have loads of kids
everywhere or be a woman that has loads
of multiple kids it's becomes a human
being that you're talking about a human
being is gonna have to be put in a place
where you're gonna put trauma on them
for no reason because they're not asked
to be born and i think that's a serious
question to have with people that you
can't be out here having kids anywhere
everywhere because you because you can
because you earn 10k a month so what
that kid needs someone there every
single day in their life to be their dad
to be their mum and i people talk about
enough
so what about you guys uh financial
abortion yes or no
yes
yeah
yeah
now i think ultimately i would say i i
just i do feel very sorry for
men when it comes to women getting
pregnant because ultimately they don't
have a decision regardless of whether
they're in a relationship or it's a
accident whatever it is it is the
woman's choice at the end of the day so
yeah i just think it's a techie one okay
so but you you at the end of the day you
would say yeah yes okay yeah yeah what
about you yeah so we all agree yes
in favor of men as well
[Laughter]
the audience is gonna switch on you
they're gonna be like you know what
she's
based what does that mean what's
basically oh based is like it's good
it's like she's cool yeah
i'm learning the lingo yeah